all right good morning everyone i'm
obviously sheriff joseph lombardo
i'm here to brief you on the latest
details in the homicidal review
journalist investigative reporter jeff
gehrman
first and foremost i want to offer my
condolences to the jeff's family
friends and co-workers at the review
journal
i want to thank our partners in the
community who have helped us share
crucial details
with the public over the last few days
from the moment lbmpd detectives were
called to the scene on saturday morning
investigators have been working
tirelessly to identify the suspect in
effect and arrest
under my direction we enacted major case
protocol
saturday to bring together the full
force of lempd
to solve this homicide
major case protocol was first utilized
in 2018
the goal is to bring together resources
to maximize the investigative effort and
ensure timely clear and consistent
communication
during a high profile investigation
additionally large amounts of incoming
information
would need to be processed
timely and with diligence
this has a visual case from the
beginning
the murder of an investigative
journalist and the main suspect an
elected official here in clark county
because of the relentless follow-up of
our detectives and with your help i'm
here to announce the rest of 5 45 year
old robert telus
he was booked in the clark county
detention center
last night on the charge of open murder
this is a terrible and jarring homicide
one that has deeply impacted las vegas
every murder is tragic
but the killing of a journalist is
particularly troublesome
who hope the rest of telus and his
subsequent prosecution will ultimately
provide a sense of justice for our
community
and mr german's family
and i would like to add our work is done
on in this case detectives are still
shifting through
information so in other words the case
is still continuing
we have several leads we're still
following up on to solidify the case and
to put to bed
other allegations so at this point i'd
like to bring dory corn captain of the
homicide bureau forward and he will walk
you through the timeline associated with
the case thank you
good morning
as you know we began our homicide
investigation about five days ago on
saturday september third
this was after we received a 9-1-1 call
of an unresponsive male that was found
on the side of his home
our preliminary investigation revealed
that the unresponsive male was deceased
as a result of stabbings
we also determined pretty quickly that
the victim was jeff gehrman as the
sheriff said
jeff garam is a well-known investigative
reporter and that was taken into account
immediately
some of the other things that were
developed pretty quickly by our homicide
investigation was that the suspect as
you see here in the photo to my left
your right
was wearing an orange shirt with
reflective stripes
a straw hat and was carrying a duffle
bag
in what was likely an attempt to either
disguise his identity or conceal his
identity
we also know that the suspect
was walking westbound approaching
german's home
on friday september 2nd the day prior to
us being notified
on that morning he approached mr
german's home and went to the side of
the house
shortly after german came outside of the
garage door
and then went to the side of the house
and ultimately an altercation took place
between the suspect and the victim
we believe this happened around 11
18 a.m
and at that time
our victim was stabbed multiple times
as sheriff lombardo pointed out
he initiated major case protocol
immediately
based on the circumstances which allowed
us to bring in a lot more resources to
address a lot of the tips and leads and
information coming from the
public our detectives and everyone
involved in this case have been working
non-stop since saturday this is a very
important case for everyone involved
and on day two of our major case
protocol we det we developed a very
critical lead which was a vehicle that
we identified
it was a maroon colored gmc denali that
was suspiciously driving around in the
neighborhood
on the morning of the murder
prior to the murder and then certainly
was there
at the time when the murder happened
that vehicle had stopped multiple times
throughout the neighborhood was behaving
suspiciously or was suspicious
the second key piece on day two was we
determined that the suspect wearing the
orange shirt had fled in that vehicle
which connected the vehicle to the
suspect
as i mentioned before in our earlier
statements
we've been working
all possible leads on this case we've
been exploring all theories and
conducting simultaneous investigations
into every piece of information we came
across
there were two main areas that we were
focused on
early on
one was ensuring that this was not
connected to a burglary series or
anything of the sort
and then two looking at any work related
grievances or conflicts related to mr
german's work
we knew that as an investigative
reporter he had written several articles
and there were different allegations and
statements about potential people that
would be upset about it
one in particular that we identified
early on was robert telus as a person of
interest
because telus had with telus was upset
about articles that were being written
by german as an investigative journalist
that exposed potential wrongdoing and
telus had publicly expressed his
his issues with that reporting and then
ultimately
telus was also upset from what we found
out later that there was additional
reporting that was pending
so at that time we began uh focusing a
little bit more on that as we conducted
all of our investigative efforts uh the
other thing that was discovered by our
detectives was there was a vehicle that
matched the suspect's vehicle
description that maroon gmc denali that
was parked in front of telus's home it
was registered to his wife and then we
ultimately developed video evidence that
showed that that vehicle the gmc denali
parked in front of telus's home had
departed around 9 00 a.m in the morning
on the day of the murder and it returned
around 12 p.m just after the murder
which matched our timeline
we immediately began working on search
warrants and then we began searching we
executed the search warrants early
yesterday morning and that involved
searching tell us his home his vehicles
and then also searching his body to
collect the dna sample to compare it to
dna recovered during the crime
at that time as you noticed yesterday we
were still building our case continuing
our investigation and we were waiting on
dna results and so telus was released as
we continue to build our case
detectives continue to work very
aggressively as the sheriff pointed out
we've built a culture around here where
we expect relentless follow-up on every
case we're involved in so they were
relentless in their efforts we worked as
quickly as possible and shortly after we
developed information that indicated
telus was driving gmc denali the morning
of the murder
we also through the search warrant
effort we recovered a pair of shoes as
you'll see here on my screen here to the
left that match the suspect's
description
also as you can see there's apparent
blood on the shoes and the shoes were
cut likely in a manner to try to destroy
evidence
in addition to the shoes we recovered a
straw hat that was also cut
in a manner that was likely to destroy
the evidence and that straw hat as you
can see matches the one in the photo uh
just something to point out that black
brim is actually the interior part of
the hat a sweat band not the exterior
part but we analyzed the hat analyze the
shoes and then ultimately one of the
most important aspects of this
investigation was waiting on the dna
results and we received positive dna
results that showed
robert tell us his dna at the crime
scene
at that time
we immediately initiated our arrest
operation and planning the goal was to
take telus into custody as safely as
possible
and thanks to the men and women of the
las vegas metropolitan police department
and leadership here we were able to
successfully execute that operation
yesterday and tell us was taken into
custody safely and arrested as the
sheriff talked about
i'll just quickly conclude my part by
saying thank you to the homicide unit in
particular we are very fortunate in las
vegas we have the best homicide unit in
the country with the highest solvability
rate in the country and they worked
tirelessly as the sheriff pointed out to
succeed in this case and then there were
a lot of supporting units from the lab
technicians to our tactical teams and
everyone else involved that did a
tremendous job as well as the media all
of you really helped us when we asked
for the help to get information out you
did that job for us and helped us and
the general public who provided tips and
leads so definitely appreciate it um and
with that as i just reiterate it's very
important we're only five days into this
case
so there is still a lot of effort as the
sheriff pointed out that needs to be
conducted and there will be more facts
as we continue to make progress on this
case but
we do
believe this is an important case and
that's why everyone involved from the
very top of our agency is the sheriff to
the to the lower parts working every
single lead took this case very
seriously because they know the impact
it has on our community and our country
as a whole
with that uh we'll turn it over to
questions and uh depending on the
questions the sheriff i will answer
yes sir
it sounds like you're on to him fairly
early this is an intentional suspect so
once he was aware that you were on to
him how would you describe his demeanor
his level of cooperation
so there's some details in the
investigation we can't reveal at this
time because we want to make sure we
have a successful prosecution but
we were conducting simultaneous
investigations into various leads some
related to telus some related to
burglaries and everything else
so can't speak to demeanor at this time
but it was successful in terms of
focusing on him and is this video that
we're showing
to what you believe was the eventual
homicide that is video of the suspect
walking to the homicide and uh video uh
to or from the homicide we have video on
both angles that we've shared with the
public since and uh it is a casual walk
even after the homicide uh yes sir great
yeah kenneth um i'm gonna ask a quick
one and then another one did you find
the orange
outfit
uh so at this time we're still finishing
our investigative effort we found the
straw hat and the shoes we're still
processing other evidence that was
recovered from the home garage door
remained open correct
we know that the
our victim exited through the garage
door
i don't have the details on whether it
was open at the time of our response but
we do have it documented was anything
taken from the home or from mr garman
at this time we do not believe that
anything was taken from the home or from
mr garman yes sir sir can you address uh
has he been cooperative during an
interview with law enforcement and can
you also address the circumstances of
them being brought out in a structure
regarding our interaction with the
suspect but i can tell you the whether
you saw him coming out on the stretcher
he had self-inflicted uh wounds and we
were trying to provide medical attention
to help him what did you just describe
the wounds that was good
uh so uh at this time i cannot describe
the wounds but they we do know that they
were not life-threatening
yes can you describe the situation of
telus being brought back home only to be
arrested a few short hours later and did
the district attorney have an influence
on why he was not arrested at that time
so
in the last press conference one of the
things i said was that it was not just
important enough for us to identify and
apprehend the suspect but we wanted to
do it in a way where we could have a
solid good prosecution so in
consultation with the district
attorney's office throughout this
investigation and certainly at the time
of determining release to continue to
build our case so um so yes
do you believe any of these
do you believe
right now we can speculate on the motive
beyond what was already discussed we
know that uh telus was very upset about
garivan's reporting already about uh his
role as a public administrator and
everything else that followed with that
um so he was brought back to the home we
saw him go back in the hazmat suit
presumably because his clothes were
taken
and then we sort of saw swat come in he
was uncooperative coming out is there
going to be any look at the fact that an
entire neighborhood was evacuated for a
suspect
with a you were you were on to him you
were i understand you were waiting for
that dna but that two-hour window could
have turned
uh
it could have been very different so is
there going to be any look at not
releasing a potential murder suspect
back to his home like that
you know though there's a reason why
people from all across the united states
come to las vegas to apply with our
agents to become police officers and
detectives and swat officers and all
that and that's because we have a very
professional and effective way of how we
safely take people into custody in these
types of very dynamic situations and
that was proven yesterday and then the
second reason is we have a community
that's very supportive so i understand
some people might be frustrated with the
disruption but the way the operation
worked the community was supportive of
how we did it and they were certainly
supportive of the outcome because
everyone is safe right we certainly
support you but he
was able to go into that home and
sources say he he inflicted self-harm on
himself obviously he was taken to the
hospital so something could have
happened in that two-hour window
so what i'm just i think we're all a
little curious when was that this why
was that decision not made
when when he and he just walked back
into the house yeah just as i am that's
not something we usually sure understood
as i answered before we we wanted to
provide a medical attention which we
were successful in doing so and then we
also wanted to make sure that we were
consulting with our district attorney's
office and ensuring a solid uh case to
keep building evidence and that's what
we did successfully thank you
yes
at this time as the sheriff pointed out
we this is five days into the
investigation we had a lot of success
early on because the sheriff enacted
major case protocol but there's still a
lot of information to go through uh
you know we we gave the information that
uh we arrested the person for the murder
but we'll still go through everything
and be able to analyze that a little bit
further yes ma'am sheriff you said the
murder of a journalist is especially
troubling
do you now is probably not the
appropriate time to talk politics but do
you
condemn
so why are we talking politics soon do
you condemn former president trump's
normalization of violence against
journalists
uh no i think this property the
inappropriate venue to speculate on that
or opine on that
i think it's uh
it needs to be stated and noted
that it is troublesome because it is a
journalist and we expect journalism
stock for government
and when people take it upon themselves
to create harm associated with that
profession i think it's very important
that we put all eyes on and address the
case appropriately such as we did in
this case with this expediency
associated with it
but let me provide some clarification on
the question on the individual returning
to the house
so that's that's dictated by the
constitution and the nrs
and the ability for an individual to
leave on their free will
until we attain enough evidence to rise
to probable cause to affect an arrest
and that was the reason why that took
place at that time sheriff also did you
have any personal involvement in the
case beyond the special protocols that
you initiated uh no ma'am no i did not
can you explain so after you had left
the search warrant and then the one
officer came back by himself
why did he come back by himself what was
he what was his intent at that point was
he planning to arrest the suspect at
that point or why was he there by
himself i'm not familiar with that yeah
just uh very briefly uh so we wanted to
make sure we maintained open
communication with mr telus we wanted to
make sure we had a safe resolution of
this so it was our strategy to make sure
we were over and provided any channels
of communication to continue as we
continue to build our case but was it
safe to have just one person there
because the short time after that you
brought everybody in swat and armed and
we well i think it's an assumption we
don't we don't
publicly talk about our tactics and and
i assure you there was more than one
person there
can you talk about the actual weapon
that was used in the stabbing was that
recovered and what was that
at this point we have not recovered it
uh we continue to search for that and
that's why uh
captain
uh corn has alluded that we're
continuing the investigation we're still
in short proximity to this and obviously
you know all the legwork continues for
the police agency and investigative
functions on a case that's complicated
and we have to ensure that we're dot in
the eyes and crossing the t's to ensure
uh successful prosecution what was
uh interviewed
did he give a statement
and or was he represented by an attorney
at that time
he was interviewed
he was consensually interviewed
voluntarily interviewed
he had the opportunity to obtain a
attorney uh he chose not to and
subsequent the termination of the
interview he was let go at that time
can you talk about the las vegas reviews
journal involvement in this case yeah
absolutely i'm glad you brought that up
because they were instrumental in one in
notifying us of the next akin
for mr german so that we could do those
appropriate notifications of the family
members before we made this public
and secondly they were instrumental in
providing us for information on his
cases that he was working previously and
currently
associated with this case and
captain
coren alluded to other
directions we were pursuing because we
didn't know absolutely at this point if
telus was the involved suspect
we had to look at different crimes
committed in the neighborhood we had to
pursue every aspect and the the review
journal provided us some additional
information on a previous case that we
had worked and made public in the uh
information in the public space as to
mo dress
and i'm sure you're all familiar with
that um and we had to run that to bed uh
as a result of the
our or the rj i'll use the rda
bringing it forward is tell us so
hospitalized
i don't know
currently or he's at clark county
detention center captain i used because
of his position
official
i'm sorry was the fbi used to offer his
arrest because he was a public official
no
we didn't feel the need to bring the fbi
in as of yet if it had gone across state
line or rise to a different level of
electronic evaluation
we very well much brought in the fbi
sure
i'll answer one more question
you have remarkable video of
the man you identify as the suspect
approaching
the
attack scene do you have video of the
attack
uh we have some
distorted video associated with the
attack and um we are in the process of
clarifying that video as we speak
captain when did telus actually become
a suspect your prime suspect in this
case and and when you came i assume you
didn't know when you had the press
conference and you were asking for help
but when you had that press conference a
couple days ago was he already on your
radar
so
this will be the last question part of
major case protocol is to look at all
leads at the same time so we had a lot
of personnel investigating very early on
telus is a person of interest
the exact time of when it becomes a
primary suspect or secondary suspect is
really irrelevant because we don't when
we over focus on one area we start
losing evidence and losing other things
so uh the reality is very early on into
the major case protocol we were doing a
lot of things simultaneously and that's
what gave us the success
i'm sorry we just can i just ask
one trade question but we will have more
information come out soon we have a lot
more facts on this case so just give us
some time it's only been five days thank
you